bugün sizlere
Türkiye'deki çok
katmanlı kültür varlıklarından onların
korunması için çabalardan Öncelikle söz
etmek istiyorum tabii ki
koruma bir bilim dalı ve mültücü
disipliner çok sayıda bilim insanının
uzmanının katkısı ile yapılan bir çaba
Nemrut Dağı
milattan önce 1 yüzyılda yaşayan birinci
antiokosun mezar Anıtı 2000 metre
yükseklikte bir tepede bulunan bu
tümülüsün
doğu ve batı yönünde ki teraslarda
günümüze kadar ulaşan büyük heykeller
var tanrılara ait
kendisini de temsil ettirmiş ve geleceği
bu şekilde mesajlar vermiş bir
kral Komagene Kralı 2000 metre
yükseklikte Kışın kar yazın güneşten
etkilenen taşların Tabii ki bozulmaları
söz konusu bu konuda koruma çalışmaları
Ortadoğu Teknik Üniversitesi restorasyon
bölümü tarafından
yürütüldü malzeme araştırmaları nasıl
sağlamlaştırılabilir kışın nasıl korunur
nasıl bir takım kılıflarla korunabilir
bu yönde bir sürü çalışmalar yapıldı Ama
henüz uygulamaya konulmadı Tabii ki
Zaman geçiyor Ve bu önemli heykellerdeki
çatlaklar hasarlarda
aşındırmaya devam ediyorlar Onun için
hem hızlı davranmak hem sürekli izlemek
ve korumak gerekiyor Bu kadar değerli
olan varlıklarınızı
Anadolu'nun başka yerlerinde de çok
sayıda kalıntılar var Roma döneminden 5
yüzyılda olan sınırda yer alan daha
rahat kentinde büyük bir
yerleşme var bir çok Savaş burada
gerçekleşmiş Onun için güçlü
bir kale yapılmış surlar bazı burçları
hala ayakta duruyor sarnıçlar var Kaya
Mezarları var bunlara baktığımız zaman
da tabii ki o dönemin sanatını
işçiliğini taş işçiliğini özellikle
görüyoruz o sırada
Roma'ya doğru Roma imparatoru
hristiyanlığı kabul etmiş Dolayısıyla
onunla ilgili
simgeleri de bu kayaya oyulmuş olan
mezarlarda görmemiz mümkün burada
bilimsel çalışmalar kazı surların ortaya
çıkarılması ve korunması önemliydi bazı
yapılar Öncelikle ele alındı Burada
gördüğünüz bir Sarnıç yapısı tamamen
kayaya oyulmuş yer altında üstüne ise
modern bir köy evi yapılmış ve köy
evinin
tesisatı vesairesi akıntıları da
bu anlatın yüzünden akıyor Tabi ki böyle
durumlarda kamulaştırma gibi
yasal durumlara başvurulması gerekiyor o
konuda Kültür Bakanlığı bir takım
davalar
yürüterek bu
önemli anıtları ve sütü daha iyi korumak
için çaba göstermekte yine erken
Hristiyanlık dönemine ait Binbir kilise
olarak adlandırılan Karaman bölgesi
Burada da öğrencilerimizle hiç çalışma
yaptık erken Hristiyanlık döneminden
kalan bir Bazilika yarısı yıkılmış ve
apsis bölümü çok tehlikeli durumdaydı
burada
belgeleme uzmanı hocamızla beraber
çalışma yapıldı kendi öğrencilerimiz de
krokiler proje hazırladılar daha sonra
Karaman valiliğini
proje hazırladık bunu destekler misiniz
yıkılmak üzere olan bir eserdir dedik
oradan aldığımız cevapta burası İstanbul
değil bizim öyle paramız yok şeklinde
oldu biliyorsunuz Emlak vergilerinden
yüzde 10 toplanıyor ve bunlar Kültür
Varlıkları için valilikler tarafından
tahsis ediliyor
Bu proje yaptıktan sonra hep ne zaman
yıkılma haberi gelecek diye korku içinde
geçirdim bazı zamanları henüz gelmedi
Çok şükür İnşallah projeyi uygularlar ve
yıkılmadan bu önemli eserdir kurtulmuş
olur İstanbul önemli bir kent ve
yüzyıllar boyu İskan edilmiş değişik
dönemlere ait eserleri var ve bu
eserlerin genel görünüşe katkıları da
çok değerli bir silüet oluşturuyor
1940'larda burada yapılan koruma
planlamaları
çerçevesinde tarihi yarımadanın
silüetinin bozulmaması için 40 Rakım
üzerinde 3
kattan daha fazla yükseklikte bina
yapılması önlenmiş bu önemli bir karar
Fakat tabii ki Tarihi Yarımada ile
İstanbul
sınırını değil galeta var daha Kuzey
bölümler var ve Maslak bölümünde Örneğin
yüksek Gökdelenler
yapılırken Belediye Başkanı
onlar rahatsız edecek silüeti diye
Burası neresi Maslak neresi gibi bir
cevapla karşılaştık Yani hem kendi
yöneticilerinin hem
vatandaşların yaşadıkları şehirle ve
onun korunmasıyla çok ilgili olmalı
olmaları gerekiyor
hem yapıları hem çevreyi korumak için
dikkatli
projeler uygulamalar yapılması gerekiyor
İstanbul Büyükşehir Belediyesi'nin şehir
anıtları arasında bakmakla sorumlu oldu
binalar var Bunlar kenti ait olan yani
kentin sokaklarını
sınırlarını belirleyen yapılar su
yapıları ve savunma yapılıyorlar
Büyükşehir Belediyesi'nin
yükümlülüğünde bu kapsamda sarnıçlar da
yer alıyorlar fakat bazı saçlar mülkiyet
değiştirmiş burada Vakıflar
devreye giriyor bu Binbir
direkt Sarnıcı'nın üzerine bir fazla
Paşa Sarayı yapılmış Osmanlı döneminde
ve fazla başı burayı kiraya vermiş Vakfı
etmiş Dolayısıyla aynı hukuki statü Şu
anda da devam ediyor O Vakıflar bir
firmaya bu Sarnıcı devretti ve onlar
restorasyonunu yaptılar içinde lokanta
dükkan şeklinde bir takım düzenlemeler
yapacaklardı Fakat böyle bir durum
olduğu zaman tabii ki o anlatın sunumu
genel görünümü zedeleniyor buna karşı
itiraz edildi ve şu anda bir müze gibi
sergileniyor
yapılmış
Aslında iki tane sütun üst üste
konularak yapılmış olan bir Anıt
diğerlerinde genellikle tek sütun vardır
fakat zamanla Toprak dolmuş birinci
sütun seviyesi hemen hemen tamamen dolu
fakat mimariyi ifade etmek için küçük
bir alanda kazı yapıldı ve orada iki
sütun yüksekliğini görebiliyorsunuz
buradaki mermer sütunlar özel olarak bu
Yapı için
İşlenmiş ve
sütunların üzerine Taşçı ustaları
imzalarını koymuşlar 4 yüzyıldan
günümüze kadar kalan bu izleri
görebiliyoruz
yine 4 yüzyıldan önemli bir eser olarak
Konstantin
sütununu görüyoruz Bizans
şehir içinde
yaptırdığı meydanın ortasında yükselen
sütun bu sütün por firden yapılmış
porfir mor renkli ve imparatorlarla
ilişki kuran bir renk Onların togaları
da porfir renginde oluyor yani
imparatorluk rengi ve
Konstantin bu sütunu roma'dan getirtmiş
Roma'da Apollon heykeli varmış üstünde
İstanbul'a gelip İstanbul'da kendi
üzerine konulmuş fakat zamanla
depremler
yangınlar sonucu bu üzerindeki heykel
günümüze ulaşamamış yangınlardan çok
etkilendiği için etrafını açanlar
sarılmış ve Türkçeleri Çemberlitaş
olarak
adlandırılıyor son yıllarda bu anıtta
belediyenin sorumluluğunda olan bir Eser
şehir içinde meydanında yer alan
anıtlardı belirlediğin sorununda olduğu
için burada da
pastane
kullanılarak sağlamlaştırma sistemi
yeniden elden geçirildi
üstlendiği çalışmalardan bir tanesidir
surlarda
[Müzik]
1980'li yıllarda Dünya Mirası
İstanbul'un tarihi alanları olunca
belediye tarafından çalışmalar
başlatıldı daha sonra Belediye
Başkanlığı değişti ve Şuradaki
çalışmalar durdu şimdi tekrar devam
ediyor 7 km uzunluğunda ve bakımı Tabii
ki çok masraflı sorumluluğu yüksek olan
bir Anıt ama bütünlüğünün korunması da
tabii ki önemli çünkü Dünya Mirası
olarak önerdiğiniz zaman bir eseri veya
bir şehri onun sürekli bakımını da
üstleniyorsunuz devlet olarak yani
sadece belediye değil
devlet olarak da Türkiye Cumhuriyeti
olarak da dünya mirasisi anıtlarının
sütlerini korunması önemli Şu anda
deprem hazırlığı şeklinde çalışmalar
yürütülüyor yani depremde yıkılabilecek
durumda olanlar kuleler için Duvarlar
için acil önlemler alınıyor etrafları
sarılarak askıya alınıyorlar
1999 yılında
burada sade gördüğünüz kule Aslında
sekizgen gövdeli bir kuleydi yarısı
yıkıldı şu anda orada uygulama yapılıyor
güvenli alınması için çalışmalar var
yıkılan parçasını da kaldırıp yerine
koymak
istedik fakat belediye oraya vinç
giremeyecek kaldıramayacağız gibi
gerekçeler ileri sürdü belki Onu
kaldırmak için başarılı bir mühendislik
hizmeti bulabiliriz o zaman Özgün
parçayı yerine koyma şansı da olabilir
İstanbul'daki
metro ve başka
çalışmalar kapsamında kazılar yapılıyor
Bu Derin kazılarda
şehrin geçmişine ait başka verilerle
ortaya çıkarılıyor Metro kazısı
sırasında Yeni Kapıda bir mendilek
ortaya çıkarıldı bu mendiliğe yakından
baktığımız zaman orada da devşirme
taşlar olduğunu görüyoruz yani ikinci el
daha eski tabakalardan çıkmış olan
bezemeli taşlar burada kullanılmış çok
değerli bir arkeolojik kalıntı onun
korunması için de yerinde korunması için
kurulu karar aldı Fakat henüz
uygulanmadı tarihi kentlerden söz
ederken Güneydoğu Anadolu'daki
Mardin'den
bir iki şey söylemek istiyorum Mardin
eski bir şehrimiz Fakat 20 yüzyılda
kendi çok kültür değişik etnik grupların
yaşadığı
şekliyle artık yaşamını sürdürmüyor bir
sürü göçler oluyor ve bu güçten
insanların yerine kırsal alandan yani O
şehrin kültürünü tam olarak
benimsemiş bilmeyen insanlar geliyorlar
ve tarihi taş evlerin üstüne iki kat
inşaat yaparak
değişiklikler yapılıyor yapıyorlar işte
orada da Mardin Valiliği ile bir çalışma
yapıldı daha sonra
Jandarma Komutanlığına çevrili olan
çevrilmiş olan bir ev restore edildi ve
müzenin ek binası olarak değerlendirildi
Mardin'in içinde değişik terk edilmiş
manastırlar da var Katolik veya Ortodoks
onlarda da çalışmalar yapılması için
girişimlerde bulunuldu fakat kaynak
henüz elde edilemedi
tarihi yapıların yeniden kullanımı
onların yaşamlarını uzatmak için önemli
bir etken arkeolojik alanlarda bazı
yapılar restore edilerek müze olarak
kullanılıyor
ortaçağdan kalan medreseler de de böyle
bir kullanım var tarihi hamamlar değişik
işlevlerle kullanılıyor Bu yeniden
kullanım meselesi çok önemli Fakat
dikkat edilmesi gereken nokta o yapının
anlamını önemini
olan çok değerli bir yapının
malzemelerini kapatılması kabul edilemez
Bu kapsamda da Trabzon'daki Ayasofya'yı
göstermek istedim çok güzel
bezemeleri var fakat camiye çevrildiği
için asma tavan ve perde kullanılarak
bunları kapatma şeklinde bir müdahaleye
gidildi
savaşlar kültür varlıklarının yok
edilmesine neden oluyor
savaşlardan sonra uluslararası
yardımlarla desteklerle
harap olan anıtların tekrar ayağa
kaldırılması için Çabalar yürütülüyor
bunlardan bir tanesi mostar'da
1997 yılında savaş sonrası mostar'a
gittiğimiz ise şehir her tarafı yıkılmış
bir durumdaydı sonra; UNESCO köpüğü
restore etti Ondan sonra değişik
[Müzik]
Maaşlar alındı Ahan vakfından başka
kaynaklardan onlarla restorasyonlar
yapıldı Tabii bu da insanların tekrar
normal yaşama dönmeleri ve
alıştıkları sevdikleri çevre tekrar
kavuşmaları sağladığı için çok güzel
2000 yılında da Kosova'da biliyorsunuz
çatışmalar olmuştu
2001 yılında priştini Üniversitesi bir
çağrı yaptı O çağrıyı çeşitli
üniversitelerden ülkelerden insanlar
katıldılar ve Bu toplantıdan sonra
değişik projeler başlatıldı onlardan bir
tanesi de yaka kentinde bulunan 16
yüzyıl sonunda ait bir cami Süleyman Ağa
bu bir çoban Osmanlılar şirin bir
çocukmuş ona alıyorlar topkap ı Sarayına
Getiriyorlar sonra para topluyor ve
Kendi memleketinde bu camiyi yaptırıyor
Böylece
günümüze ulaşan önemli bir sanat eseri
ortaya çıkmış oluyor Umarım Kültür
Varlıkları Barış ortamında bilgiyle ve
sevgiyle yöneticiler çok değerler bizim
yaşamımız için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]